I had the privilege of meeting our next
speaker and his lovely wife penny when I
came to Claremont California in the fall
of 1994 to study for my PhD in political
science at the time he was president of
the Claremont Institute he didn't teach
any formal classes back then but he was
always teaching whether in conversation
or in his speeches and I learned a lot
as many of you know if you if you claim
to know something in his presence that
makes you something of a ripe target you
can ask our students today at Hillsdale
who he'll drop in on from time to time
at the lunch table and ask them
questions like so what is the good and
like any good teacher he wasn't afraid
to tell you if he thought you were wrong
which he did to me quite frequently so
back then when I was younger and sillier
I used to joke that he was a college
professor trapped in a think tank
president's body I guess that makes him
a professor trapped in a college
president's body now of course all
joking aside those two things go
together at Hillsdale as they used to at
least at most other colleges and
universities in addition to serving as
the 12th president of Hillsdale College
he he teaches courses on various topics
including the Constitution and Aristotle
he's the author of several books most
recently Churchill's trial Winston
Churchill and the salvation of free
government it's been my privilege and
honor to work with him at my alma mater
now for almost 16 years his topic today
is education and politics please welcome
to the podium Hillsdale College
president Larry P Arne
good morning thank you Tim Tim was a
tremendous young man back then is he is
a tremendous man today but he still
confuses the term stature and size I've
been having a wave of the last few days
of missing Ronald Reagan do you miss him
in there
mine was provoked by I go on the radio
and talk about the election all the time
and haven't got a position in on the
election that I'm prepared to announce
I'm in the college business and I know
things about it so I talk about those
things and what I succeeded in doing is
making everybody mad but I watched and
it was probably not judicious I went and
looked up Reagan's speech after his
speeches after his primary victories and
the main one that made the big
impression was when he won the whole
thing and that his first words were he
walked up and he had that big smile and
he said this is the most humbling moment
in my life and then he stopped for a
while you see if you go read his first
inaugural address that's the opening
theme and then the end of that very
their brief remarks but they were just
dynamite is like the end of his his
first inaugural he says this is a very
troubled time and we are in danger he
said but we are Americans still and so
we are not afraid and he said that was
such firmness you see and he was telling
us this is our country that's why we
miss him and also we miss him because he
addressed the crisis that we're in
pneumatically is still the same crisis
and I will say that the intensity of
this election which I have actually been
enjoying for the first time since Reagan
ran is because there are people
in this race who do address this crisis
de matically I'm very aware that this
could be disaster for us and that we may
have a disaster no matter what happens
in this election this I think is the
third great crisis in the history of our
country after the American Revolution in
the Civil War I think this might be the
age in which we lose control of our
government but I also think we should
remember that back when Reagan started
you couldn't know for sure that he was
going to turn out to be Ronald Reagan
it's hard to tell Aristotle says power
shows the man so I begin with the point
we should be hopeful you're important to
do that sooner or later we're gonna fix
this for one thing my college won't be
able to go on if we don't and that's not
a supportable idea it is going to go on
I'm going to make three points
this is an intense election because
we're in a crisis and I'm going to
explain what that is I'm going to say
that this crisis began in the world of
education and has afflicted the world of
education almost to the place of
destruction and that the solution to the
crisis in education and the solution to
the crisis in politics are the same
solution and deeply related to education
so those are my three points the word
crisis means turning turning from one
thing to another
it means if we that we're going to be
either the same thing having turned back
to it or we're going to be something
different when we're finished
that's how serious it is and I'm gonna
give you a tool to understand things
like this this is like political science
101 and excuse me for doing it but I
find the argument I'm about to explain
to you very beautiful and I hope you do
so in the metaphysics Aristotle says
that anything human beings produced
and can also anything in nature but just
stick one things humans produced can be
understood by the four things that make
it what it is it's four causes
everything think of a statue I was
taught this by a very great man who died
last year both my teachers died last
year Harry Jaffa and Martin Gilbert I
was so lucky in both of them they're
very different kinds of people but both
awesome and Harry Jaffa explain this to
me and he explained it in in regard to
what he regarded as the greatest statue
have you ever seen Michelangelo's David
in it awesome well it has a material
cause it's made of white marble and that
changes a lot of things about it
because if it was made of bronze it
would look different you know it was
made of green plastic it would look
different the United States has a
material cause this land and the people
who live in it and they are a unique
opportunity in history not only had such
a thing never happened before but it can
never happen again and what was the
thing what what was was that a
civilization highly developed moved to a
new continent there aren't any more new
continents this continent nobody knew
what was there in fact Washington named
his army the Continental Army but it was
not until more than 20 years later that
any representative of the United States
ever crossed the continent to actually
see how big it was it was this vast new
world and as far as they know it was
empty and the people who came they
brought with them enormous things right
learning the Bible books tools all of
that but when they first got here they
didn't have the capacity to make any of
that what they did also bring with it
what changed
as the aristocracy the hierarchy of
things of people and things that had
prevailed in the old world that was
wiped out and everybody got to start
over if you like western movies
Doug Jeffrey over there is a great
expert on Western movies and other
extremely important things but that may
be the most important that he knows
about he he will tell you that Liberty
valance the man who shot Liberty valance
is a very great one and what what is it
about there on the front - you tear and
there are two kinds of rule their guns
and their law books and nobody in that
town could make either a gun or a law
book they came from before and they
brought them with him and now they're on
the frontier and they have to work out
the relationships again to get the law
books in charge of the guns that's what
the talk was about last night by the way
you see so the material cause of America
is this unique opportunity of land and
people and then things have a a
efficient cause Michelangelo made the
David it was hard to do right it's
manual labor to sculpt in marble you got
a chip away he said you know you take
you take a point way the parts of the
rock that are not too statue I wish it
were so simple but then we wouldn't
revere Michelangelo so much right him
working away
that's the efficient cause the efficient
cause of America is the people who built
it and you know the leaders of those
people are very remarkable people and
you can read what they did and why they
did it because they were particularly
explicit careful to explain what they
were doing there's no founding of any
country so well documented or explained
as the founding of the United States of
America and of course there were huge
arguments about it but they did that
they did it and then things have a
formal cause so that's the efficient
cause the person who did it him doing it
them doing it her doing it there were
some hers of course else there wouldn't
have been any hems you can say men come
first but that's stupid
don't you have mothers or don't you have
wives so then there's the formal cause
that's what it looks like Michelangelo's
David looks like David he was a boy he
was chosen by God to do a mighty task
he's got really big hands and in the
statute he needed to sling those stones
you see long arms a kind of innocent and
yet firm countenance right you could
look at the qualities he had you know
it's sort of divinely appointed to do a
great heroic act you could have a statue
of a horse that that looked like that
there have been horses who've been
appointed to great deeds and celebrated
in poems and songs but if David had been
a horse it wouldn't look the same right
the formal cause is that boy and then
there's what's the formal cause of the
United States of America how do you see
the United States of America how does it
act the answer is it acts as a people
through three branches of government and
that gives it its form and back when
those branches worked the way they were
supposed to they were very distinct so
it was when it was time to figure out
what to do about a thing then the
Congress would deliberate and argue and
then passed some law and we would know
what the law was and we would follow the
deliberations and it used to be that the
laws passed in Congress were the only
laws that there were and you know
Congress still today passes about the
same number of laws that it passed 150
years ago
of course now there are thousands of
laws passed every year but not through
Congress anymore that's a change in form
of the government and then when when the
government got ready to do something to
act then that's in the White House the
president acts he executes a very
interesting word and then and then when
there's a dispute in an argument between
people or between people and the
government or one part of the government
or the other then somebody judges and
that's the Supreme Court and what does
that tell you except that the structure
of the Constitution itself it's divided
into those three parts plus four others
the others you know that there's it goes
legislative executive judicial then
there's one about the states then
there's one about ratifying the
Constitution I may get the last three in
wrong order
what about ratifying the Constitution
one about the transition from the old to
the new constitution and what about the
amending process the Constitution
essence is the form of the government of
the United States and it is reflected in
the way Washington DC looks because the
great buildings the old buildings which
are all very beautiful and designed
according to a common theme have you
noticed in pictures of Hillsdale College
that Hillsdale College looks like itself
you know we've built a lot of buildings
you can't tell it people say to me some
of these buildings are new aren't they
and I say yeah pretty new and they say
who built them and I said well Adam we
built them and they said they look like
the old ones I said yeah they don't
think huh the college has a point it
should look like it has a point
we don't think at the college like you
know I'm in the college president game
which is a questionable profession and
and it's very common among them that
when they get to build a building you
know because first of all that's their
legacy they get their name on it my
names are he's not on any of the
buildings and and then they like to
build them so they look different
the others so everybody can recognize
there's right Hillsdale College is not
built that way new or old and Washington
DC old is not built that way there's a
place for each of those things and that
place is lovely and it is designed to
accommodate those things now the form of
the government I just told you it has
changed because all the three functions
of execution legislation and
adjudicating they've now been
decentralized but they're but and so
they're located in hundreds of places
all over the administrative agencies of
whom I've never been able to of which
I've never been able to discover an
accurate list
I don't know that such a list could even
be made but if you look in Washington
it's changed the face of Washington DC
they've built many many more buildings
than they used to have and they are in a
different form they that they are made
to house a different kind of functionary
and what's in the new buildings wouldn't
fit in the old buildings there's no
place for that kind of thing
these functionaries by the way are
bureaucrats and the buildings look like
bureau they look like the top of those
roll-top desk with the pigeon holes
right you can tell what's constitutional
if it's in a pretty building it is and
if it's an ugly building it isn't
it's true I mean it's it's not simply
true but it's mostly true so the form
has changed and then there's this cause
that matters more than any other and
that's the final cause what is the final
cause of a thing well if you ever been
to the Sistine looked at the Sistine
ceiling been in the Sistine Chapel in
the Vatican did you know that
Michelangelo is up there he put himself
there and what he is he appears as an
empty down skin and I don't know why he
did that exactly but I do know that that
was a great struggle to him it was hard
for him to do everything he did he gave
his life to it he sweated over it he
broke his health over it he emptied
himself out for it
why would he do that the answer is love
he loved things he wished to represent
them he wished to pay homage to their
beauty he wished to make them visible to
us he could see them and he wanted it
for us to see them go see the David it's
in Florence and it's in a big building
big Museum and you turn a corner and you
look down a hallway that's longer than
to that thing right there and the
hallway has arches on other side very
beautiful and various of his sculpting's
are on one side and another as you walk
and the ceiling is very high and arched
and that the end of it stands this very
tall statue at the top of a very high
plant and when you stop and look at it
you just stop and you just saying
goodness gracious we took a cruise to
braum in Florence and the stupid cruise
line proposed to take off Florence after
it was all set up and we called him and
you know a whole bunch of people were
coming on this Cruise Line with us and
we said you
you can go wherever you like oh right
but I can tell you 300 and some of your
guests are going to Florence because
they need to see the David you know what
are you fools and they change the
itinerary back right so do you see what
that means that means that the beauty of
the David drew us is it drew
Michelangelo the thing you love the
beautiful thing that you love that's the
answer to what do you live for and what
would you die for what is that in
America Abraham Lincoln says every
nation has a central idea from which all
its minor thoughts radiate that's
classical philosophy put to English
poetry which is what he could do in this
country he says it is the idea that all
men are created equal
no one is born with the saddle on his
back or another booted and spurred to
ride him by the grace of God in America
it's possible to grow up in Pocahontas
Arkansas the son of a schoolteacher and
absorbed with the milk that you drink
that you can do anything anything you
try hard enough to do and have the
talent for you see the only check is
nature itself in your own industry and
nobody I can't remember anybody saying
that to me but I can't remember any
conversation that was not built on that
premise when I was growing up of any
importance you see it's what the nation
loves I'm saying there's a change in
that and it started in education I'll
read it to you
this is in our Constitution reader you
can learn all this stuff by the way it's
six hundred and fifty pages everything
I've said so far is in that book just
read those six hundred and fifty pages
and then again and again and again and
again
this is a man named Frank good now he
was one of the founders of modern
progressivism he was what was he taught
at Columbia with John Dewey he became a
head of Johns Hopkins he was one of the
founders of the American Political
Science Association of which I am proud
to be a dissenting member he in 1984
several friends of mine one is in this
room were at the American Political
Science Association and they took a
straw poll of the gathered 2000
political scientist Reagan versus
Mondale and Mondale got 94% and Reagan
got less than half the rest and so there
were four or five of us and we were
having a drink and we said I I think I
might be the one who said it I said so
2% of the people here are for Reagan I
bet we can name every one of them
sitting at this table and we made a list
and we could that means that it's
probably true today every political
scientist who's conservative in America
is probably known to me and my closest
friends
we're dissenting members good now writes
the political philosophy of the 18th
century was formulated before the
announcement and acceptance of the
theory of evolutionary development the
natural rights doctrine that's like laws
of nature and of nature's God say that
you have these self that it's a
self-evident truth that you have these
rights you know that old-fashioned claim
the natural rights doctrine presupposed
that society was static or stationary
rather than dynamic or progressive it
was generally believed if you can
believe it at the end of the 18th
century that there was a social state
which under all conditions and at all
times would be ideal the rights which
man should be that the rights which man
had were believed to come from his
creator curious idea these rights
consequently were the same thing as they
once had been and would always be the
same but now everything is different by
the way did you catch the tone of this
this means that he expects his audience
to agree with this this is all in the
past tense
you see now we know the accumulation of
capital the concentration of industry
all that stuff is new and because it's
new all the principles have to be new
and it was foolish ever to think
otherwise you see that means the thing
he loves Frank
good now is something different than the
thing that Thomas Jefferson loved it
means that the final cause is different
and what does that mean for the formal
cause you know the structure of things
here's what your wilson friend and
colleague of a kind with good now the
only academic to be President of the
United States a bad idea
Jefferson Road this is Woodrow Wilson
writing of the laws of nature and then
by way of afterthought and of nature's
God
I don't always says it's an afterthought
they constructed the government as as
they would have constructed an orrery
which is you know we're all right so in
class we turn to crank and the planets
went around the Sun and the moon goes
around the earth chains hook it all up
there was a time when people thought
that was really cool the Constitution
was founded on the law of gravitation
the government was to exist and move by
virtue of the efficacy of checks and
balances the trouble with the theory is
that government is not a machine but a
living thing it falls not under the
theory of the universe but under the
theory of organic life it is accountable
to Darwin not to Newton you heard
Goodenow say they didn't really know
about social evolution right that's why
they didn't know how things are so as
the final cause must change Wilson and
good nah say so the formal cause must
change we must have a different kind of
government now I'll tell you why that
matters in very specific terms the old
thing which was in fact written under
the laws of nature and nature's God and
was in fact thought that this is the
form of government that will prove to
Accord best with human nature the old
thing did a very remarkable
constitutional arrangement it is in my
opinion one of the few but there are a
few really dramatic inventions in
America inventions they thought better
to accord with how things are and it's
this they they designed this big
government and if you just imagine the
whole society is a big circle and the
government is a little circle in the
middle of it nor on an edge right and
for most of American history the
government has been
10% of the gross domestic product of the
country and and the 10% if he divided
into that's that circle into into
segments the biggest segment would be
local government and the next biggest
biggest segment would be state
government and the smallest segment
would be the federal government all
that's reversed now because much bigger
and it's much more centralized but
because this big circle and then this
little circle because they were
different they could have relations and
the first constitutional check is that
all of the sovereignty all the
legitimate power to rule is placed in
the big circle among the people but all
the power to act is in the little circle
in the government so just think what
that does that places a check on us we
have all the power but we can't act
except at election time
it's the reason today is important and
November more important right but then
inside the government they're checked
because they don't really have any
authority of their own there's nobody in
there named King for example who's the
sovereign and the people don't meet as
legislature to pass the laws and so
they're always dependent for their
authority on the thing outside and that
in my opinion is the first step in the
key to the Constitution United States
and there are a few other steps and
they're all like that and they're
wonderful and that's why the
Constitution has lasted so long but now
if you just imagine that the little
circle becomes a little more than half
the whole as it as it has so now the
little circle is the big circle and all
the powers of government are in there
then all of a sudden the government is
an enormous factor in the electoral
process it's huge and the danger is that
people will be overwhelmed by that that
is what I think is a specific danger
that we
today and how we going to break out of
it well that's what this election is
about and that's what people are talking
about in this election including some of
the candidates
here's something crank good now wrote
about education because you'll see that
these are exactly the same thing
politics and education cos see well I'll
tell you that in a minute he writes we
teachers perhaps take ourselves too
seriously at times we may not have
nearly the influence we think we have
changes in economic conditions for which
we are in no way responsible bring the
in they're trained regardless of what we
teach changes in beliefs or opinions do
you get that point it means that you sit
in the classroom and you learn
have you heard me quote two of my
teachers today and I'm an old man now
and the teachers have just died very old
men when they died right but I remember
like it was yesterday many of the things
they said to me and you know several of
them I live my life but they give shape
to this thing that I'm saying right now
and in in my life I have students now
and I've been doing it for 16 years and
so some of them are grown and some of
them are important and I'm like their
dad like their dad in this too they're
getting to the place now where they
start telling me what to do and they
they have an expression for me when they
do that because some of them are very
powerful people now and some other
powerful people in politics where I have
certain influence and they all get to
advising me and confining me and saying
make sure you do it this way you know
because I'm gonna go talk to their
bosses and their big powerful staffers
now and I and I'll say well ok who are
you talking to again and then not long
ago I overheard one time say to another
one well he never has been a tame lion
has he I'm very proud of that right I'm
very proud of the fact that they try to
tell me what to do this relationship is
sacred
it's joyous it's wonderful and good now
says no
they think is going to be dominated by
the principal surrounded by they sorry
not principals the conditions around
them do you see what that means that's
what evolution is about social evolution
it's about the idea that as conditions
change our thoughts conform and that
means there isn't any nature to study
the AAP guide calvert I'm pretty sure
found it for me then he lost it and I
gave it back to him so I returned the
favor in secondary literature goes like
this in the introduction written by a
professor from Agnes Scott College this
may be by the way out of date this one
was published in 99 but it's not out of
date the new one will be worse it says
we used to think that there was
literature but now we know they're only
literature's objectivity and factuality
are out the door now we teach students
so first of all if you read Shakespeare
was it easy have you read it enough so
it did become compelling cuz that's the
process because he's you know he's very
great he's he's probably the best he's
probably like Michelangelo probably like
Rembrandt God made them messengers they
can tell us things and when you see that
for the first time then the archaic
language turns into music and it swells
but
it doesn't start that way now at first
it's complicated and old-fashioned
sounding and everybody thinks it's that
way when they start how do you get them
to keep on you tell them it's magic and
we're gonna teach you what it is this is
gonna be great
it's gonna be hard it's gonna be great
you see but if it's old
it can't be great it strips that
argument away at the same moment that it
lays the ground for a constantly
involving government where rights
themselves do not mean the same thing
from age to age that's the crisis it
threatens everything you hear the
sheriff last night is that the sheriff
sitting there hi sheriff
and I just want to say in public I
didn't do it so what did he do last
night
why was it compelling you know what I
was thinking about who is the greatest
American it has to be George Washington
in my opinion what did he do what he did
was first of all in the beginning he was
a bad general he had any fought right
here you know 20 blocks that way was the
heart of the battle south of here
he'd never moved any large bodies of
troops around and the British generals
were extremely good and they just danced
rings around him embarrassed him that
miracle he escaped with anybody from New
York 1777 early in the year right but he
learned how to do it and the next thing
you know I mean seven years later he had
conquered and expelled from our country
the greatest military power on
earth and then he quit people thought we
want him to be king anyway we've got to
build the new government around him he
said hush your mouth
I'm going home he gave his sword back to
the Congress made a ceremony of it and
departed you see that's the pattern of
his life enormous use of force changed
whole battles with his incredible
courage and determination and then
stopped and gave us a chance to pick
somebody else couldn't had the country
without that when the sheriff saluted us
last night he was reenacting the career
of George Washington who are we right
Hey his whole talk was spiced with the
fact that if a cop tells you to do
something you're gonna have to do it and
on the scene you're just gonna have to
do it right or wrong and they'll kill
you if they don't Lindh later we'll find
out if it was a lawful order which is
the check on the executive power right
he acknowledged all that but you know
part of it was you need to understand
while we are and the idea that we're
gonna be turned into nannies and
managers of the details of people's
private lives we can keep the peace and
enforce the law he said right and then
he saluted us our government isn't
acting that now those people used to be
most of the government now they're a
small part of it but don't make the
mistake and think that the government is
not interested in law enforcement they
are very interested in law enforcement
the EPA apparently and the Department of
Education I read has swap cops they
raided the gibson guitar company looking
for illegal would shut the place up
busted things around came in and for
with their machine gun showing right
then found out there wasn't any of that
there so they're interested in force but
they're not interested in the kind of
force that enforces laws that we can all
understand and that feels compelled not
just to protect but also to serve us
because it works for us Americans are
not supposed to be afraid when they see
a cop they're supposed to think good
news there's a cop here maybe I'll need
some help but if I do I'll get it how
does school work we have 13 charter
schools now the Hillsdale Academy three
more charter and we're running what by
every measure is one of the best
colleges in the country all you have to
know is the same doctrines that are in
the Declaration of Independence you have
to know the learning is in the student
not in you they can all do it
Jabar teach a child to talk no one ever
did there isn't any place to start they
just learn they hear and they watch and
they learn and they all do it they saw
the mystical amazing thing that every
human being can do and no other being on
earth can do and they all learn to do it
and by that act by the end of the second
year they are on their way to knowing
Shakespeare and physics when you get
them to school the first step is simple
you have to associate what they have
learned is they have learned that sounds
represent things in nature chair dog man
paper microphone right there are many of
all of those things
how do they know every time they see one
they know it's that and this is the
sound for it other beings cannot do that
Aristotle says animals then use their
voices to indicate pleasure and pain but
humans use theirs to distinguish the
just from the unjust and the
advantageous from the disadvantageous
speech is our gift now marks on a page
called writing it's just the same thing
in a different form the reason you can
always teach them to read except in the
rare case of an impaired child is
because you teach them to associate
these sounds that they've already
figured out for themselves with the
marks on the page and they're bound to
learn to do that in fact you'd almost
have to stop them learning but it can be
done quickly if you make it systematic
the head of the Business Roundtable is
the former governor of Michigan and a
really great guy I pine for him today
and I spent a couple of hours with him
not long ago and he said do you think
the Business Roundtable should make it a
national goal to teach every kid to read
by the third grade and I said well I
think they do in kindergarten he said
kindergarten you know and then he went
and got his education guy right and he
says he says they can do it in
kindergarten so I come out you know and
I don't teach kindergarten so - I know
and so and so I asked my staff Kilgore's
sitting back there somewhere where he is
he's really great he's just a weenie
and I said you know I said kindergarten
is that fair and he said well I'll be
safer to say the first or second or
third grade and I said well you know I
can't they read in kindergarten well he
said well they can't read the Federalist
Papers and I said I said can you
I find them difficult right so then I go
the next day just so happens to my
daughters our daughters elder eldest
daughter runs one of the charter schools
in Austin Texas and I'm in the class
with the awesome mrs. Reardon who
teaches kindergarten in this school and
I've been in her class three times now
Wow
she's just dynamite and I said the class
ended you know and I'd learned what
capacity was you know capacity you gonna
today we're gonna learn see hey P hey
you know they're all you know G says
capacity and they go it's a magic you're
in the thing right and I said you know
one of my guys says to me that you can't
reliably teach them to read by the end
of the kindergarten and she said shame
on him who was that you see but why if
you can do that why can you do it you
can do it because they are born with the
capacity to do it because they are human
do you know what numbers are words are
symbols for things in nature
numbers are symbols for the quantities
of those things we all know that if we
teach that everybody can read
Shakespeare and the Federalist Papers
and at least get through precalculus
I've been disciplined not to say
calculus all our kids have to get
through precalculus in our charter
schools right
they all have to learn Latin it's just a
language they can learn it if you turn
away from those natural meanings of
things you discord destroy education and
law and freedom and civilization with a
single stroke that's what's happening
and because of it a knight will descend
upon America if we don't stop it and the
good news is it isn't very
to know how to stop it we must restore
the laws of nature and of nature's God
because after all they do call to us
daunting thank you
okay we have time for a few questions we
have two students with microphones and
if you raise your hand the microphone
will be brought to you right down here
in the front I see
how far do you think we this country has
gone walking on the road to serfdom and
and what is the end point going to look
like well how far do you hear that how
far on the Road to Serfdom and what will
it look like well a long way and it
looked like serfdom no it what is the
good of freedom which includes of course
justice has to so the good of it is we
all get to work and cooperate and do our
jobs
it's the reason else Dell College is
successful everybody rose the boat you
see we don't think of ourselves as
providing a service to them we're all
providing each other a service United in
a common activity we all have to do to
go so the glory of America is there's
never been such an engine to unite
people's efforts toward common
achievement it's like a really good
baseball team for example where they all
seem to be doing individual performances
but they win because they cooperate so
there's a there's a college down in
Guatemala and I know a lot of people
down there it's good college and the
kids long to come up here and one night
down there I took a bunch of them out to
dinner about 20 of them and what they
noticed about America was that
everything works
so now the first thing that will start
happening and is beginning to happen is
that things stop working also things
can't be paid for anymore that are
fundamental defense the cops the roads
the bridges and despite the fact that
we're borrowing enormous amounts of
money from the future we can't pay for
basic stuff which it used to be the
whole of government also we subsidize
people in ways of life that are not good
for them right they don't it isn't good
to live your life without working way
better to work so those things are
beginning to happen now our public
discourse is now mostly all about what
group you're in the thing is a great
engine to take care of the newly
identified groups and there's another
one every week now
you can't keep up with them all
I prepared not to discriminate I just
can't remember who I'm not to
discriminate against so I actually try
to follow the follow the practice of not
discriminating against anybody which
requires teaching and treating everybody
the same it's not complicated in
Hillsdale College because we don't have
any rules not to talk bad about any
particular group we just have lots of
rules about being civil to everybody and
you know lots of rules it means there's
just one you have to be civil civility
is the necessary ground friendship is
the sufficient ground and you can't
become friends if you're not civil to
each other so we make them do that right
so the dysfunction is advanced now it is
masked by technology
because you know technology is wonderful
right it's just so good right I have my
iPhone here but you know I've been doing
the same kind of work for a long time
and in very important ways it's become
easier and you know I have to travel all
the time and keep up with a whole bunch
of stuff and that's just a lot more
possible than it used to be so so a lot
of the decay around us is masked by real
achievement too but you know in the last
stages and there's some of this now you
really have to mind what you say and
then you know then if I'm teaching a
course on this next term
have you read CS Lewis and have you read
Aldous Huxley
have you read George Orwell and have you
read
Winston Churchill because they were
contemporaries and they had many of the
same things to say and I'm teaching a
course where we're gonna read those
similarities and they're very different
people right but they saw what's going
on the abolition of man and I will tell
you one thing I like about this election
is that and here's the opportunity this
is why Churchill thought he could beat
Hitler overwhelming force on the side of
Hitler obviously from the military view
simply hopeless and what he thought is
he has to be vulnerable this is ugly
people won't like it or they won't like
it for long
now it's just a case that 65% of the
American people right now say that they
are afraid of their government there has
got to be a major political opportunity
in that and in this race there are some
signs
of that people from outside the minority
party which is what it is flocking to
people who promise radical reform not
just Donald Trump so I look at things
like that and think you have to remember
I mean first of all I say I believe it I
think that this is like the Civil War
and the American Revolution and those
things were won by the skin of our teeth
right what was it like in 1940 how'd
they get through that you know the
answer is only just and most of the time
thinking they probably wouldn't you see
so it's like that
there isn't any reason to despair
there's actually huge reason to hope and
you know if you want to be Spartan about
it and you do then there's this final
reason to hope in the end you cannot be
compelled to stain yourself are you
prepared to stand up and to claim
against all this despite the fact that
it's powerful that may be a dangerous
thing to do but it's a good thing to do
in that sense we are infinitely far from
the Road to Serfdom
dr. Arnn I would like to stay that
freedom to me
is the right to discipline my child if
we might view he's not behaving excetera
so I feel some of that power is being
taken away from us by the government
yeah and it remember when that with
Adrian Peterson was he the one who was
banned from the NFL because they beat
his kid with a switch
and so I got a class that day the day
that happened and you know the students
at Hillsdale College are younger right
I was beaten with a switch were you
beating with a switch you know I don't
remember it being Pleasant but I said in
my class I said how many have you ever
been beaten with a switch
they were like 10 um we all DUP their
hand I said Wow no wonder you're in
Hillsdale College this this is easy for
you now but I will say that I think you
should be allowed to discipline your
your children and also my children I'll
send them to you yeah ma'am you want to
say something he's bring it he's
bringing the deal he's not as quick as I
hoped he'd be
my question is is when you appropriately
point out that the regulations are now
having more rule over us than those that
we elect what do you foresee in the in
terms of it becoming so onerous that we
can no longer control those regulatory
bodies with the appointed people and
that our legislators have then
transferred all of the power to them and
at what point the scales tip do do we
challenge that and do you feel we can
challenge it in a court of law
no I I don't I agree with I have a lot
of controversial views and I'll
apologize for them
I've been unwilling to join the chorus
to say that Donald Trump is unfit to run
for the presidency United States
although whether I'm for him or not is a
different question and and I also don't
think the courts are the heart of the
problem I think Hamilton was right the
courts are the least dangerous branch
and the reason they are is because they
are farther the people and because their
work proceeds from particular cases that
arise and we have lots of modern
examples that when a resolute Congress
or executive branch stands up to them
they Bend and what they're very powerful
at is that when it's a close-run thing
and Obamacare is passed by both branches
and the people are very divided about it
you know it's very unpopular but they're
plenty of supported to then they get a
lot of leverage and they have a lot
because of that but if there's a
political decision in the country about
the direction of the country they will
fall in line with it I predict as they
have in the past in my opinion
consistently
more question doctor I guess at this
time I'm still very concerned your
comments on the folks in the American
professor is that group and everything
how liberal they are and how liberal the
press is and I don't think they're all
stupid people but what is it they don't
see that we see so well yeah that's a
really good question and there in my
opinion they're neither stupid people
nor corrupt one of the reasons by the
way I'll bring this up again that I
don't tend to denounce people running
for president is that first of all I'm
not in the line of work but second I try
to follow the example of Lincoln and
Churchill who could make devastating
arguments against people but personal
attacks were more rare so now I'll say
about those professors there you know
there are obviously tremendous people
they have enormous talent you know to
get an academic knowledge of a big
subject takes decades and diligence and
so these are and they're not as a rule
corrupt people nor by the way our
politicians in my experience the trouble
is in my so this and see this is a huge
thing to say right but I believe it I
think that this thing by Frank good now
that's very gloomy to say that what you
teach your students won't really
influence them all that much that's kind
of a despairing point right but on the
other hand turn it around because if
it's true that we are shaped by the
social conditions two things follow one
is it's a very important fact that we
know that now and that means we can
focus our attention on those conditions
and we can take control of them we can
make the society into whatever we want
the whole direction of historicism in
Germany and progressivism in America
it's just it's child and you know I I'm
not saying anything controversial that's
who they quote when they talk about what
they think Hegel and Kant and those guys
write but but just think this this is my
surface problem right I write on a type
on it it stay synched up all the time I
carry my remarks down here I don't have
to go find a printer you know I used to
my life used to be driven by looking for
a printer and you know I never looked
for a printer anymore it's great it's
liberating but this is really obviously
competent and so john dewey writes for
example we must take the techniques that
have produced this and we must apply it
to people we must plan and organize the
whole society by the scientific method
and then we can make it is much better
than the old society as this is of a
computer five years ago you see that's
the plan and there's a great hope in it
everybody can have whatever they want
you see in our news is bad news
obviously bad news why why do I say to
prospective students in Hillsdale
College you got to remember it's hell I
say to him all the time you have to
suffer you know my class that was so
tired the other day I said remember you
have to suffer let's get to it
and they all go okay we're gonna suffer
let's do it right you see what if he
didn't have to suffer that's the hope of
course it's compelling nobody wants
anybody to suffer it's just that if you
persuade yourselves that the moral and
the end well
quote the great man in the first speech
ever given by President United States
George Washington says our Republic is
founded in the great fact in the whole
course and economy of nature the
indissoluble connection between virtue
and happiness virtue means courage you
might have to suffer virtue means
moderation you might not be able to
enjoy many things if you banish the idea
that you have to suffer there will be
endless suffering that's the trouble
thanks
thank you